Spider-Man across the spider-verse
premiere to Stellar reviews and love
from audiences but no movie is perfect
and even the best spider stories
sometimes even answered questions
warning spoilers ahead although across
the spider-verse features a wide variety
of cameos that highlight Spider-Man's
impact on pop culture no Cameo was more
surprising than Donald Glover's
appearance the last time fans saw
Glover's Aaron Davis was back in
Spider-Man homecoming where he portrayed
a wiser than expected Thief Spider-Man
stops can I give you some advice
you gotta get better at this part of the
job I don't understand
I'm intimidating given Davis's history
in the comics his deep connection to
Miles Morales and just meaningful
interaction with pizza in homecoming
many felt that Davis's appearance would
lead to prowler and Miles formal
introductions to the MCU however he's
been completely absent since seeing him
appear here is especially noteworthy as
he is dressed as Prowler the only
mystery now is what this appearance
means is this an official look at
Glover's Prowler or just a fun Cameo for
fans if this is a legit hint or Glover's
Prowler appear in Sony's Spider-Man
universe or will he appear in the MCU
for now it seems like Sony will keep
Glover's fate as Prowler mystery and
fans will be left wondering if and when
they'll see him again
While most of the main spider Heroes of
across the spider verse are given a
moment to delve into their backstories
Miguel O'Hara Spider-Man 2099 is cut off
before he can tell a story in this scene
where he talks about how he became
Spider-Man When Stacy Cuts him off
before he can even start still we learn
a couple of things about him throughout
the film when telling miles about why he
forms a spider Society Miguel talks
about his own experience in disrupting
the cannon that ties everyone together
he explains that his presence in another
world caused it to vanish entirely this
leads him to form the spider Society to
help stop anomalies from breaking the
Multiverse other characters have also
explained that Miguel holds some kind of
vampiric power which could explain his
sickly look and it might even provide a
backstory to the serum he injects
himself with so what actually is the
backstory of Spider-Man 2099 in the
comics he isn't exactly a vampire but he
does have some unique powers after
attempting to recreate Spider-Man's DNA
Magellan fuses his DNA with that of a
spider causing him to gain stations
outside of the normal Spider-Man Powers
Miguel also has spider-like fangs that
lets him inject paralyzing Venom into
his foes so he has a horrifying side
Miguel is no ordinary Spider-Man and
it'll be interesting to find out more in
the sequel It's established right from
Hobie Brown's bombastic introduction
that he's an anarchist who's known for
toppling hierarchies and empowering
those around him to Rebel that doesn't
change when he's a part of the Spidey
Society either from getting Gwen to Vibe
with his rebellious ways to teaching
miles how to break the shield placed
around him is pretty obvious that
hobie's got something in the works
behind the scenes when Miguel commands
the entire spider Society to stop miles
Hobie takes the opportunity to quit and
go his own way he also provides Gwen
with a bootlegged portal device that she
uses to recruit her own allies given
McGill's influence and power over the
entire spiderverse it's surprising that
hobie's rebellious plans flew under
Miguel's radar perhaps he thought Toby
couldn't influence other spider people
to take him on and Miguel did say he was
trying to ignore Hobie however it seems
like a big oversight especially with
Hobie having such a history of rebelling
against the system and it's a crucial
Flora Miguel's thinking that's
ultimately going to come back to bite
him given How Deeply these spider-verse
films delve into the Multiverse a few
characters have been oddly absent Madame
web a blind telepath who uses the spider
Versa contacts other Heroes and helped
them fight crime is especially notable
maybe there's a greater plan at hand and
my damn web will have a bigger role than
beyond the spite of us or maybe Sony
will find a way to bring them a damn web
from the upcoming live-action film based
on a character where she will be
portrayed by Dakota Johnson into this
animated conflict regardless Madam Webb
is still missing from the spider-verse
films but will hopefully appear
somewhere down the line as shown in the
film's big chase sequence where mild
sleeves from nearly every Spider-Man in
existence Miguel is quite an army at his
disposal with just a simple command he
can send every Spider-Man variant into
battle
stations drop what you're doing and stop
Spider-Man
it's soft to imagine any foe who can
stop all of them with this powerful Army
in his hands it's a little strange that
Miguel only brings Spider Woman and a
Scarlet Spider with him back to Miles as
well given the importance of their
mission to let miles's Dad Jeff meet his
tragic fate you'd think Miguel would
want to do whatever it takes to make
sure it all goes according to plan maybe
he's just losing it from all the
injections he's given himself under
pressure of the Multiverse breaking is
finally getting to him but it's clear
that Miguel continues to experience
lapses and judgment or maybe considering
how many spider people got in the way
while chasing miles a small Elite Strike
Force is a better idea than bringing
spider Rex into Brooklyn one of the
biggest lingering mysteries of across
the spider verse is what will happen if
miles saves his father and breaks a
Spider-Man Cannon every Spider-Man goes
through a time when a beloved police
captain or someone very close to them
dies in their arms miles's dad is about
to become the new police captain the
young Spider-Man sees visions of his
father's death which Sparks his desire
to break the cannon Miguel says that it
could be catastrophic if miles us but
beyond the brief glimpse of the massive
hole that forms an
earth-50101 after miles saves inspector
Singh and not much is explained perhaps
the spot will end up winning and start
to consume all the other universes
perhaps nothing will happen and these
concerns are just simple paranoia beyond
the spider-verse will hopefully provide
some kind of answer that'll shock and
surprise fans not only were there plenty
of incredible appearances of Spider-Man
variants from animated series and video
games but there were also several
live-action crossovers the spot pop
sends out a chat with Miss Chen from the
Venom films and the Donald Glover
appears as Prowler in the anomaly
containment room across the spiderverse
definitely shows a live-action film some
love we even get to see scenes from
Tobey Maguire and Andrew Garfield's
Spider-Man films where Miguel is
explaining the Canon events the only
question remaining is whether or not
this means that there will be more
blending of animation and live action
for future Spider-Man films for beyond
the spider verse it's a Surefire
guarantee but what about the other
live-action Spider-Man movies perhaps
we'll see Gwen the spots or other the
animated Spider-Man maker cameo in
future live-action Spider-Man movies
across the spiderverse sets a new bar
for Crossovers and there's plenty of
potential for that to continue in
unexpected ways once the Sparks figures
out how to travel between universes he's
on a mission to gain enough power to
become Unstoppable after obtaining
enough chaotic material to become
completely covered in the spots that
were once speckled around his body he
takes a daunting new form his body color
has gone from white to black with white
swirling dots floating around his body
by the end of the movie he has
re-entered miles's world and prepares to
unleash absolute destruction that could
potentially kill miles's father how is
anyone going to stop the spot by this
point he seems all-powerful and though
the Canon says that Miles eventually
defeats him after his dad dies there
doesn't seem to be much of a plan
currently the spot was tough to fight
even when miles first met him and now
he's far more formidable miles climatic
fight with his Nemesis is inevitable and
will have to come up with quite a plan
if he's looking to save his father from
a tragic face
once miles finds himself in a universe
where there is no Spider-Man many fans
likely wondered what his variant would
be up to in this world with his uncle
Aaron alive and his father dead this
version of miles takes up a different
mantle that's far less heroic in a
suspenseful and shocking reveal miles
learns that this version of himself
becomes Prowler how did this come to be
the assumption would be that after
miles's father dies he turns to his
uncle Aaron for guidance which leads him
to become the infamous villain however
there's no confirmation of whether this
Prowler is the same kind of villain with
miles under the mask beyond the spider
verse will surely let this version of
Miles get his origin story and likely
give fans a better glimpse into the
chaos filled Earth 42. before he became
the spot miles's foe worked as a
scientist at Alco Max and brought the
spider from Earth 42 into miles's
reality the effect of this is that there
is no Spider-Man in that Dimension but
miles has transported to Earth 42 at the
end of the movie as a result of his
altered DNA he sees what a world without
Spider-Man looks like crime runs rampant
fire can be seen from every rooftop
there are constant reports of crimes
being committed across the city and
Spider-Man not existing likely
contributed to Jack Morales death at the
hands of super-powered criminals are
there other Marvel Heroes on Earth 42
it's never confirmed if other Heroes
exist or not but it's likely they don't
given all the chaos and Carnage seen in
the streets it's safe to say that Earth
42 is without a super powered protector
perhaps as Doom's reality is a chance
for the spider-verse films to highlight
the anti-heroes of Spider-Man stories
like morbius black cat and silver Sable
by the end of a Crosser spiderverse
tensions between Gwen and Miguel are
high Gwen even questions of the members
of the spider Society are even the good
guys anymore we
with Hobie sparking her rebellious side
we learned that Gwen has built a spider
team of her own with old and new friends
their goal is likely an attempt to stop
Miguel's hunt for Miles this begs the
question and we're about to see an
all-out spider Civil War unfold with
time running out on the impossibly high
stakes of her Mission there's definitely
a massive conflict building Beyond
miles's conflict with the spot Greta's
already assembled a pretty strong roster
of spider Heroes and who knows if she'll
try to recruit more to her side Miguel
is a vast Army for any kind of battle
that unfolds so if Gwen is going to go
head-to-head with him he's more than
ready but it seems like Miguel's
position is about to be challenged and
Beyond the spider verse will host the
biggest Spider-Man brawl of all time
beyond the spider verse has been pitched
at the end of the spider-verse trilogy
and miles's story but it's tough to
believe that this will really be the end
there's so much more to the spider-verse
that can still be explored aside from
giving select characters around spin-off
films the next shout to drop the spider
verse could take some inspiration from
the comics and have the vampire Moreland
service a new island in the comics
spider heroes from across the Multiverse
are forced to come together when Morgan
and his powerful family the inheritors
Traverse a Multiverse to fulfill a
prophecy of killing all the Spider-Man
variants it could be a great storyline
that sees a different spider people come
together after the events of this
Trilogy and payo Mars to the spite of
her storyline from the comics plus given
how beloved and financially successful
these films are it's doubtful that Sony
will want to stop it beyond the spider
verse there's a lot of amazing potential
for these movies outside of just miles
beating the spot that makes the future
of the spider-verse very intriguing
foreign
[Music]